Now you remember from
last week that we're in the
moment of phasing
out of the 1960s,
moving into the
1970s, but of course,
human actions,
inactions, chronology,
is not simply as
neat as dates on a,
on a calendar as a
timeline. A lot of the
social confusion, violence,
and cultural excitement
actually, of this era,
of the late sixties,
is right there in the
1970s. And this lecture's
actually trying to canvass
some of the political
turmoil and its, its
marriage to popular culture
in the early 1970s. By
way of context though,
let me start in the spring
of 1970. On April 30th--and
actually, let
me focus--it's,
frankly, just focus on two
weeks in 1970. On April
30th, President Nixon
announces the invasion of
Cambodia, escalation of
the war in Southeast Asia in
general, and the need
for one hundred and fifty
thousand more troops to
find a lasting peace.
In response, the campus
at Kent State in Ohio,
the ROTC building is set
on fire. The Ohio governor
dispatches National Guard
to make sure that the campus
remains
peaceful. On to May 4th,
this attempt to keep
the peace on Kent State
evaporates, when
twenty-eight Guardsmen open
fire on Kent State students,
killing four and wounding
nine.
Immediately--immediately
being a day--five hundred
colleges are shut down
across the country, or
they're disrupted from
protests. Our country,
according to college
protestors, our country is
now attacking us. It makes
tremendous
headlines. On May 14th,
ten days--[student sneezes]
bless you--ten days after
Kent State, at
Jackson State University,
a historically
black university,
during a student protest,
state and highway patrolmen
open fire with automatic
weapons into dormitories.
Allegations are that someone
was sniping at them. No
evidence was
ever found to that,
to that end. They opened
fire without any warning,
killed two students and
wounded nine. The scale of
national attention is
not commensurate with what
happens at Kent
State. So for,
in the African
American community,
there is a sense
that the police state,
in this case, state
and highway patrolmen,
could kill our college
students without anybody
worrying too much,
but at Kent State,
also inexcusable, that
if you kill the students,
it becomes a national
catastrophe. Meanwhile,
in New Haven, just about
two blocks from here--well,
actually, all throughout
New Haven--the Black Panther
Party and the FBI are at a
standoff. Black Panther
Party and fellow travelers
had come to New Haven,
essentially to protest the
murder trial of Bobby Seale,
who's accused of authorizing
the murder of Alex Rackley,
member of the
Black Panther Party,
people believed to have been
an informant to the FBI.
Fifteen thousand people
descend upon the Green,
Panthers,
Panther supporters,
sort of anarchist
hippies, called the Yippies,
by--led by Abbie Hoffman,
fellow travel--travelers of
all sorts. And there was a
real fear that the city is
going to be collapsed into a
race riot. The university,
under the leadership
of Kingman Brewster,
the president at the time,
does something that people
never expected, and actually
opened its doors to the
Black Panthers. It
created a mechanism,
it felt--Brewster felt, that
would relieve some of the
pent-up anxiety and tension
over what's happening around
the country and then
locally. Classes are
canceled; there's student
strikes. I think two or
three pipe bombs go off at
Ingalls Rink. It's a level
of chaos that you, that
you are not familiar with.
Kingman Brewster declares
that he actually doubts--and
I'm paraphrasing
here--whether a black person
can get a fair trial
anywhere in America.
Immediately, the
alums start phoning in,
calling for his resignation,
for his outlandish
statement. It's
a national event,
student unrest; it's a local
story as well. In this
spirit of what's going on in
the country on the college
campuses, and the
nation, the call for federal
troops--excuse me, for
more military troops,
the invasion of Cambodia,
you have an astonishing,
almost sort of a call
and response by a lot of
cultural artists. Most
famous in this regard--well,
most famous to me at least,
in this regard--is Marvin
Gaye. Marvin Gaye, who had
made a career at Motown by
piecing together and
performing love songs,
branches out a year later in
May of 1971 with something
really quite different.
So he's known for,
for this: [Marvin
Gaye, Tammi Terrell,
"Ain't No Mountain High
Enough" excerpt plays.]
Listen, baby Ain't no mountain
high Ain't no valley low
Aint no river wide enough,
baby If you need me, call me
No matter where you are
No matter how
far Don't worry,
baby I mean, really
catchy love songs,
really quite--you know,
they're actually important
in the history of the
evolution of rock music and
the Motown sound. But
by--when we get into 1970,
Gaye is
wrestling with, well,
partly exhaustion
from churning out these
saccharine-laden songs,
but also he's wrestling with
what's going on
in the country,
and he wants to aspire to do
something quite different.
And he earns, secures
himself a new contract with
Motown and he's
given creative license,
which is astonishing. This
is the big sort of rupture
in Motown. He's
given creative license,
and he turns--and he
generates a concept album.
The album's called What's
Going On? It's dealing with
Vietnam, it's dealing
with economic despair,
with incredible inflation
going on in the country.
It's dealing with
ecological despair,
and this is a few years
before Earth Day would
actually take effect, when
people are wondering what
we're doing to this
particular planet. In fact,
I've often, when I've given
this lecture--and I wanted,
I hadn't given a, a cultural
politics lecture for years,
and I finally realized it
was time to do so. And I
listened to What's Going On?
Just to see if I
wanted to play a clip,
and I realized, I could
actually just put the CD on,
leave the room, have
you guys understand the
nineteen, early 1970s by the
time the album was over.
But, well, I have to get up
and say something. So you
have a moment of
escalating war in Vietnam,
fear of, of
destruction of the planet,
ecologically speaking,
environmentally speaking,
hyperinflation in
the United States,
poverty, urban decay. And
Marvin Gaye starts writing
these pieces, or produces
these songs. They merge one
into another in
What's Going On?
and, in fact, if you do want
to learn about the 1970s,
just go out and--I used to
say buy the album at the
record store, then
you could buy the CD,
and now it's just,
you know, go to iTunes,
I suppose. Although you
should patronize Cutler's,
the local record store.
[Students laugh] One of his
signature songs
from the album,
"What's Happening,
Brother?" It's the story of
a returning vet,
comes back from Vietnam,
trying to figure out what
is happening on the street,
really trying to get back
into the mundane routine
of life.
I'll play a clip of it.
Hey baby, what you know good
I'm just getting back,
but you knew I
would War is hell,
when will it end, When
will people start getting
together again, Are things
really getting better,
like the newspaper said
Whatelse is new my friend,
besides what I read,
Can't find no work,
can't find no job my friend,
Money is tighter than
it's ever been Say man, I
just don't understand
What's going on across this land
Ah what's happening brother,
Oh yeah, what's happening,
what's happening my man?
If you have the lyrics
sheet in front of you,
it's self-evident. For
those of you who don't,
the guy's just come back
from war. He's wondering,
if he's reading
the newspaper,
if what he's
reading is true,
and he's talking
about civil rights here,
of things actually getting
better. Can't find a job
though, money is tight.
"I don't understand what's
going on around here."
And then just wondering,
you know, are they still
doing stuff they used to do,
going to the dances? Do you
think anybody has a chance
to succeed, in this case, a
ball club? "I want to know
what's going on, what's
happening." Someone who's
lost and trying to
find his way. Very soon,
you get an answer
in the same album,
in the song "Inner City
Blues." Harkening back to
Gil Scott-Heron,
"Whitey on the Moon."
Dah, dah, dah,
dah, dah, dah, dah
Rockets, moon shots
Spend it on the have nots.
Money, we make it;
'Fore we see it you take it.
Oh, make me wanna holler
The way they do my life.
Make me wanna holler, The way
they do my life.This ain't
living, This ain't
living No,no baby,
this ain't living
No,no, no. Inflation,
no chance, To increase
finance. Bills pile up sky high.
Send that boy off to die.
Make me wanna holler.
The way they do my life
Make me wanna holler
The way they do my life.
Sending people to the moon?
Spend it on people who don't
have anything, please,
instead. People taking all
of our money. This is
exactly Gil Scott-Heron's
lament from the same
era. He closes the song,
throwing up both my hands in
a lament. Now if you think
I'm stretching this
just a little bit,
I mean, this is
just one album,
after all, let me share with
you a personal story. It's
happening in 1971, '72,
and '73. I was too young to
remember it, actually,
but in 1990--let me think,
when would this
have been--1997 or so,
I was living in Los
Angeles. My father and
mother had come to
visit me and my wife,
and we're driving. We go
out to--he'd lived in L.A.
for a while when--during
this era--we drive out to
visit some old friends
of his in Los Angeles,
have a great
night. Come back,
we're driving back and I
happen just to put on this
album. I listen to it all
the time. He and my mother
riding in the back
seat and after a while,
I realize what--something
doesn't sound quite right.
And then I realize, what I'm
hearing in the back seat is
weeping, I mean, flat out
weeping. I turn down the
music, ask what's going
on, and my father just says,
"I can't--you know,
I just can't talk,
can't talk about it." Get
back to the house. I've
never seen this guy cry in
my entire life. I don't
know what, what has actually
happened. I sit down with
him and my mother
says, "Wendell,
just tell him what's
going--what happened
there." And my
father essentially had a
flashback. He was a
Vietnam vet himself,
fought--flew in the Air
Force. And he's saying that
album just brought
everything back. I mean,
"You just don't, you
just don't understand,
he tells me, "what it was
like." People going off and
trying to--risking their
lives for their country,
and being treated the way
they were treated upon their
return. And Marvin Gaye
really understood the sense
of confusion
that many people,
not just the vets, but
certainly in his case,
the vets come back trying to
figure out what is going on
in this country, what do
they actually fight for?
Feeling a sense of moral
confusion as well. My
father even
talked about the,
you know, the economy and
the ecological landscape,
all in that same
moment. He goes,
"That album really captured
it all. Marvin Gaye
understood what was
going on." Now this album,
What's Going On?, fluctuates
between the international
critique and also
things happening in U.S.
cities, again, this
economic despair,
I keep coming back to
it. It's really one of the
defining elements of
the time. You also have,
during this
moment, this rise of,
in, in line with the
Black Panther Party,
certainly, this rise of
a celebration of black
masculinity, black virility,
and also black cultural
celebration. Quite a
different one than the
Harlem
Renaissance, certainly,
but a black cultural
celebration all the same.
Take these
elements together,
sort of this
culturally rich moment,
the notion of
abiding economic troubles,
and also
determination that we,
in this case the black
man--and I use that phrase
quite intentionally--are
going to turn the system
over. We're going to
be something different.
You end up with an
incredibly popular movie and
character. The character's
name is John Shaft,
and the movie isShaft. I'll
play for you some lyrics,
show you a clip, and then
explain a bit of what is
actually happening
in this piece.
Who's the black private dick
That's a sex machine to all
the chicks?
Shaft!
You're damn right!
Who is the man that
would risk his neck
For his brother man?
Shaft! Can you dig it?
Who's the cat that
won't cop out
When there's
danger all about?
Shaft!
Right on!
They say this cat Shaft
is a bad mother--
Shut your mouth!
But I'm talking about Shaft.
Then we can dig it!
He's a complicated man
But no one understands him but
his woman - John Shaft!
Every year when I play
this, I forget to do a vocal
boost, because the
lyrics--Isaac Hayes's voice
is so deep, that you
lose out on the lyrics.
"Who's the private--who's
the black private dick
That's a sex machine to
all the chicks?(You're
supposed to say "Shaft!")
[Students laugh.] You're
damn right!
Who is the man that
would risk his neck.
For his brother man?
" "Shaft!"
Thank you. [Students
laugh] "Can you dig it?
Who's the cat
that won't cop out.
When there's
danger all about?"
"Shaft!"
"Right On!
You see, this cat is--this
Shaft is a bad mother."
"Shut your mouth!"
"But I'm
talking about Shaft."
All right, you
get it. Anyway,
I mean it is,
it is humorous,
especially when
looking like this,
and being what I am,
and singing this song.
[Students laugh] But,
but the song was incredibly
important. Isaac
Hayes breaks out as well,
out of the
Motown sort of trap,
and comes out with this
album that electrifies
people. He's talking about
a kind of individual they
had not seen before, they
had not been around before.
And then the movie comes
out. I mean this was the
soundtrack to the movie.So
you're walking through New
York, Time Square,
which used to be a complete
cesspool.
I'll fix it.Come on,
get out of the way.
Want a timepiece, brother?
Now I played the extended
clip here. There's a couple
of moments that are rather
important. One is just the
street scene that Shaft is
walking through. New York
City, Time Square, is not
the place you've come to
know with its, with its sort
of carnival atmosphere. It
was a place of, you know,
triple-X movie theaters,
prostitutes, drug use and
such. And John Shaft comes
up, emerges in
this landscape,
and walks through it, a man
on a mission. Thirty-four
seconds into this clip,
into the start of the movie,
you may have seen it or
not. I don't know if the
lights were down
enough yet for you,
but he crosses the street
and someone comes up about
to hit him. He stops
the car and gives them the
finger. You know, in the
grand scheme of things,
especially with what we
see today in our movies,
in our YouTube
clips, this is,
this doesn't even register.
This was a mind-blowing
moment in American cinema,
when this movie comes out.
A black man, walking through
a place like he owns it,
giving the finger to
a white guy in a car,
and he continues walking.
He's walking through,
his long, leather black
coat. Certainly reminiscent
of the Panthers, but
he looks a little bit
different. And
it turns out,
when this guy tries to
sell him a hot timepiece,
that he's a cop.
So the question is,
who's the man?
Shaft!
Yeah, thank you! [Students
laugh] Well played,
yes. That Shaft is
the man. He's virile,
he's masculine.
As the lyrics say,
"he's a complicated man."
And so you have a new kind
of visual representation
of blackness. [Student
sneezes] Bless you.
Now Shaft is one of the,
the finer productions of
a, of a cultural moment in
cinema called
Black--blaxploitation.
Pardon me, I have to
multitask a little bit
here. Blaxploitation
begins in 1971,
begins, you know, all in
this moment. It begins with
the movie, really an art
piece by a man named Melvin,
Melvin Van Peebles.
The movie's called Sweet
Sweetback's Badasssss Song.
The movie is--I find it
very difficult to watch,
just from the kind of
messages it's giving,
and also because of
its cinematic qualities,
and because it's
in some way--well,
I don't care for the movie.
But anyway, it's incredibly
important. It starts with
the unnamed
narrator, or protagonist,
I suppose, seen being
raised by prostitutes,
he becomes a hustler. He
becomes witness to a moment
of po--police brutality. He
kills a bad cop and because
he committed one of
the ultimate offenses,
he has to go on the run.
And the movie is essentially
him--it's a flight movie.
He's going through all
these different scenes,
trying to keep one step in
front of the man. And the
man, as it turns
out in this case,
is powerfully corrupt.
There's a lot of power;
but that power has corrupted
him. And you see Melvin Van
Peebles, he's the
lead in his own movie,
you know, going through I
mean any kind of slice of
life you can imagine,
representing the 1970s: drug
use, sex scenes,
pimping, prostitution,
crime, always trying to stay
one step in front of the
man.And the movie becomes
an inspiration for the
formula that
becomes blaxploitation.
It's a movie that
dismisses assimilation,
that declares the system's
corrupt. It is a reflection
of Black Power militancy, no
matter what it's a counter
to white hegemony. This is
how you could characterize
most of the blaxploitation
films. There are wrinkles;
we'll get to that in a
moment. But I want to play
for you one of the last few
clips of the movie. What
you're seeing here, it's
a, it's a strange close up,
the camera looking
down in a shallow creek,
panning up to
see a, to see a,
a gutted, a gutted police
dog that had come to hunt
down the narrator. You
see it from a slightly
comfortable distance.
And again, it's a, it's a
movie that's about flight.
It's actually hard to watch
because of the dissonance
and the rough film quality.
Well, the movie's shot on a
five hundred thousand dollar
budget, shot in the
course of two weeks,
has an all-black crew. So
it's giving a message about
sort of a
non-assimilationist black
pride and it's actually
doing it as well. And the
movie--oh and I think it
aspires for an X rating,
which had a different
connotation early seventies
than it does now, because
that way they could get
outside of the union system,
and then have an all-black
crew. Shot for
five hundred grand,
grosses two million--ten
million dollars,
excuse me, ten
a tremendous return on
investment. And this is
what really launches this
five-year period of the
genre. They are
often low budget,
Shaft being really a
different creature in this
regard, it's a high budget
film. Most of them are low
budget. They make a ton
of money. The production
values aren't that
wonderful. They're mostly
action films. They're
very simplistic in its
construction: black is good,
white is black--bad. They
are hyper-masculine, and
they're misogynist.So when
people think
about blaxploitation,
is it about black identity,
about a certain kind of
blackness? Is it about
cultural production? Or was
it a co-opted capitalist
venture? AfterSweet
Sweetback's Badasssss Song,
most of the blaxploitation
film--films become studio
productions. No matter what
you decide
blaxploitation is,
it's important to think
about the images that it
presents. They all weren't
about revolutionaries or
tough upstanding men.
They're about different
kinds of people. I'll play
a clip from the movie Super
Fly as a way to access
this particular part of the
narrative.
I'm your mama,
I'm your daddy,
I'm that nigga in the alley.
I'm your doctor when
you need want some coke,
have some weed.You
know me, I'm your friend.
Your main boy,
thick and thin.
I'm your pusherman,
I'm your pusherman.
Ain't I clean, bad
machine super cool,
super mean.
Feeling good for the man.
Super Fly here I stand.
Secret stash, heavy bread,
baddest bitches in the bed.
I'm your pusherman.
So this is a song
celebrating a pusher."I'm
your mama, I'm your daddy,
I'm that nigga in the alley.
I'm your doctor when
you need want some coke,
have some weed.
You know me,
I'm your friend.
Your main boy,
thick and thin."
So who is the pusherman?
I'll play the opening
montage from Super Fly.
The main character is
getting out of his car.
That is the main,
lead character.
You with me or not?
Yeah.
Next mother
fucker come in here,
we off him, right.
You got that shit?
The filmmakers
didn't need a set;
they had New York
City. Used it as a perfect
backdrop.
So I played this extended
clip the same way I played
Shaft. I mean these
movies are coming out at
essentially the same time,
but they're telling quite a
different story. Walking
through different parts of
New York City, certainly.
Shaft walking with power and
authority, since
he is the man,
and the pusherman doing
something really entirely
quite different. Still,
also walking through New
York City and its
economic--sights of economic
devastation. Right
before this clip,
you see the pusherman
getting out of bed. He has,
as the lyrics in the
Curtis Mayfield song,
"the baddest
bitches in the bed,
getting out of bed
with a white woman,
which is of course
important for all the racial
narratives about that kind
of coupling possibility,
living in a very
fancy apartment,
and he's really trying to
get out. He's made enough
money, trying to get out of
the system. Then he's got
to get these petty thieves
who are trying to take some
of his, his dope.The story
is then about a pusherman
trying to exit the high
life. He's going to make
one final score
and retire. But he,
as the story goes through,
he discovers that the people
who are actually
the drug pins,
kingpins in New York City,
the ones he has to make this
final score with, are the
police. The commissioner of
the police is the
biggest kingpin,
drug kingpin in the city,
and the pusherman comes to
the heroic
conclusion, by framing,
or setting up, the police
commissioner. So you have
here perhaps a hero, perhaps
an antihero. It's really
quite unclear, but you
certainly--I mean in terms
of what's being celebrated
here--but you certainly have
the lingering part
of blaxploitation,
that the man, when it is the
white man--not John Shaft of
course--the man, usually a
person of great authority,
structurally in the system,
is the cause of degradation
in the black community.Now,
I've talked about the fact
that blaxploitation is
celebrating manhood of a
complicated nature. It's
also doing something quite
different. You know, people
often point to Pam Grier as
a wonderful example of a
blaxploitation film star.
You know, she's always
winning in the end. One of
her first movies
in this regard,
Foxy Brown, is a story about
Foxy. Her brother is set up
by drug kingpins. This is
one of the great narratives
of blaxploitation. Her
boyfriend is killed by the
man, and she's going to
infiltrate the mob to exact
her revenge. And the
way she infiltrates it is
becoming a prostitute.
In fact, at the
beginning of the movie,
before this stuff
un, un, unwinds,
you have Pam Grier getting
out of bed with the phone
ring, phone rings. And
within a few seconds,
she's bare-chested. I mean
this is what blaxploitation
and white--and, and female
power is suggested by Pam
Grier, her sexuality
is her power. Anyway,
I want to play the last
couple of minutes from Foxy
Brown. It has a twist on
this narrative of who's the
man, in fact, how Black
Power is interwoven in this,
in interesting ways.What
you're seeing here is the
drug kingpin's boyfriend
being stopped. Black
mobsters have taken
over. Posing as the police,
and now they've caught him.
What are you going to do?
What do you want? What are
you guys going to
do? What are you crazy?
What do
you--He's ready, sister.
No, you--You're crazy. You
can't do this! You can't do
that! No! No,
Foxy! Oh no,
you can't. [Screams.] And
this is the drug kingpin,
as it turns out, the
person behind Foxy Brown's
boyfriend's
murder, her brother,
her brother being
set up as well.
The alarm's been tripped.
Hold it right there, spook.
You're going to be a spook
for real pretty soon. Hands
up.
Don't pinch the
fruit, faggot.
You watch your mouth
or I'll--No Eddie,
later.
I want to know what
she's doing here.
I'll take that thing now.
Sure, I brought it
for you, Ms. Pimp.
Like I said, it's a present
from your faggot boyfriend.
See what it is, Eddie.
[Man 2 opens the
bag] What is it?
I don't know, it looks like
a pickle jar or something,
Bring it here. Oh, Steve!
[screams] [Foxy pulls her
gun out and shoots Man 1 and
Man 2. Woman 1 grabs a
knife. Foxy shoots at
her.] Why don't you
kill me too? Go on,
shoot, I don't
want to live anymore.
I know. That's the idea.
The rest of your boyfriend
is still around. And I hope
you two live a long time.
And then maybe you get to
feel what I feel. Death is
too easy for you, bitch.
I want you to suffer.
Super bad.The
party's over, Oscar,
let's go.
So you have in this clip
justice being exacted along
the terms that in the
black--blaxploitation
vernacular made the
most sense. But still,
what kind of messages are
being offered here? And
when you were in
the movie theater,
I mean the production
value, the acting and such,
you know, in the, the gun
being pulled out of the
afro, these are
all humorous,
but in the movie theater,
these are moments of
celebration. This is a
whole different kind of
cultural logic that
people had not seen before,
not on a screen, and they
wanted to celebrate it.
It's an era of great
struggle for the nation,
truly. We're still not out
of that moment. And you'd
see it articulated with its
great cultural products of
the age. It's a
moment of despair,
it's despair that's
certainly likely what urged
Stevie Wonder to write
some of the most socially
conscious lyrics of the
era. And are--and these
are, you won't be surprised,
these are not the ones that
are heard on the radio
when people play back,
you know, Stevie Wonder
reflections.Wonder had
negotiated a new contract,
just like Marvin Gaye had
done before, that broke him
out of the studio system in
Motown, and re--and the
result was about a six-year
cycle of albums that
was nothing short of
astonishing. I mean,
one, that the albums are
released, so many are
released in just a five-year
window--actually, just a
four-year window when you
think about it. Albums are
Music on My Mind in 1972.
He's only 21 years old.
Talking Bookreleased the
same year, in '72.
Innervisions is released in
'73. Fulfillingness'
First Finale in '74,
Songs in the Key of Life in
'76. This is not the Little
Stevie Wonder of--he's
coming out with Motown
with--I'm forgetting the
name of the song--playing
his harmonica, but a Motown
sort of dance tune. This is
not the Stevie
Wonder in later years of,
you know,
"Don't Drive Drunk,
thing. This is Stevie
Wonder of a different kind
of political vintage. You
can hear it here in this
song "Big Brother."
Your name is big brother,
You say that you got me all
in your notebook,
Writing it down every day,
Your name is I'll see you,
(Your name is I'll see you,
I'll change if you
vote me in as the pres,
President of your soul
I live in the ghetto,
You just come to visit
me 'round election time.
I live in the ghetto,
Someday I will move on my
feet to the other side.
The sound quality's much
better. I had the settings
off on this, I apologize.
But in this song itself,
he's going on, You know,
"I live in the ghetto,
Someday I will move on my
feet to the other side,
My name is secluded, we live
in a house the size of a
matchbox, Roaches live
with us wall to wall" He
concludes the song with,
"You've killed all our
leaders.
I don't even have to
do nothing to you;
You'll cause your
own country to fall."
This is a different
kind of Stevie Wonder,
of course.
Now, Wonder is using lyrics
that are call and response
to Jesse Jackson.
Now we've not talked about
Jesse Jackson pretty much at
all in this course.
We'll be talking about it,
I think, next week. But
Jackson has made a name for
himself with a
famous call and response,
"I am somebody." "I
am," and the audience says,
"Somebody." Trying to boost
up in these rallies sort of
the notion of self-esteem.
And Wonder's saying,
"No, my name is Nobody.
My name is Secluded."
Incredible economic violence
and despair. "You have
killed all of our leaders.
I don't have to do nothing
to you to cause your own
country to fall. The nation
is going to
collapse in upon itself.
"So you have, then, across
in the early years of the
1970s, and this lecture's
really focused on about four
years, three years, three
or four years in the 1970s,
a moment of incredible
cultural production,
but of a type
that sends, well,
a range of messages, I
suppose. It's talking about
black virility and at a
moment of rising black
feminism, which we'll be
talking about on Wednesday,
sends very
interesting message,
"interesting" in quotes,
interesting not in a good
way, messages about the role
of the black woman. Still
wrestling with tensions
over who "the man" is,
what the man looks like,
what the man does. Who's to
be blamed for the
excesses? In a sense,
profoundly co--confusing
messages about the cultural
celebration of people who
are putting drugs into the
community and destroying
that community. As you walk
out, I'll be playing
"Village Ghetto Land" from
Wonder in 1976. He was
inviting people to come with
him down to his
dead end street,
to Village Ghetto Land: See
the people lock their doors,
While robbers
laugh and steal,
Beggars watch and eat their
meals--from garbage cans,
Broken glass is everywhere,
It's a bloody scene,
Killing
plays--plagues the citizens,
Unless they own police."
Not the most
uplifting lecture,
I know, but this is the
cultural moment of the early
1970s. We'll overlap and
we'll start talking about
black feminism in the same
moment and see a series of
conflicting messages
about blackness in the
early 1970s. Class is over.
Would you like to
go with me,
Down my dead end street,
Would you like to come with
me, To Village Ghetto Land,